Like to play a quick round of.
Drewth or Dare.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
Okay, we have Liam Charleston here, hello, Liam.
Hi, Liam.
Hello.
Hi.
Hi, Liam.
Hello, lovely to meet you all.
That's a fake accent.
Yeah
It's not, I promise it's not fake.
(Robin laughing)
Where are you from?
I'm from Melbourne in Australia.
Oh, wow!
Australia.
(audience applauding)
Alright, what's it gonna be, a drewth or a dare?
Ooh, mine is a dare today.
Ooh!
So back home in Australia, I'm a teacher
and I love playing this game with my students.
Yay, we love teachers.
So you see just in front of you there, there is two bowls.
So using the straw, I challenge you to try
and move the candy from one bowl to the other
using only the straw
and the challenge is you only have 30 seconds.
So you've all got to try and beat each other.
And we're gonna put a little friendly wager on this,
if that's okay.
Oh!
Oh yeah, what is it?
Alright, we're gonna divide up with the audience.
Robin will go on the left.
Okay.
And Ross will go on the right.
Hi, you, hi.
(audience applauding)
And I am lucky enough to have our front section-
Okay.
in our club chairs
and whoever wins, that part of the audience
is gonna go home with a treat.
Ooh!
Yeah, hey!
I got you guys, I got you guys!
(audience applauding)
I don't wanna mess it up.
Right, everyone, ready?
Oh, my God!
How do we do it?
(audience shouting encouragement)
(buzzer buzzing)
Time's up!
Is that it, is that it?
Time to pass out.
(audience laughing)
That was, that was-
Good Lord!
I cannot breathe.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Did I do it? We all did really good.
(all speaking together)
We gotta count them?
Alright.
Do we count them?
Okay, count them.
Shoot, I might pass out.
Oh, Jesus.
No, I think you won, I think you won.
You did great. Okay, ready?
I'm so lightheaded, two, four, whoops!
I think you've won.
I don't know, yours looks way fuller than mine.
I have 19.
19!
Yeah, you won.
How did I win, if we both have 19?
We tied.
How many do you have?
Less than 19.
(audience laughing)
We tied!
(audience applauding)
You people get treats.
Give everybody treats.
Alright,
that means we've got our club chairs and the left side,
but you know.
We'll give it to you.
We can't do that to you, everybody is gonna go home,
(audience cheering)
because our friends at Zolli Candy are the best
and every single one of our audience members is going home
with a delicious candy bundle from Zolli Candy.
Wow, look at that.
Right!
So thank you so much.
Good job.
I'm so dizzy. (laughing)
I'm so dizzy.
Me too!
Cheers, you guys.
Cheers.
Well done.
And a third season of "A Black Lady Sketch Show"
premiers tonight, you guys.
(audience applauding)
Yay!
Tonight on HBO.
(melodic upbeat music)